this is Grand Master Daniel narditski we
are watching Magnus Carlson taking on
the Indian Phenom gukeshta maraju at the
2023 Norway chess Blitz tournament and a
handshake gukesh starting magnus's clock
and 1v3 a surprise as early as move one
by the ever versatile Magnus Carlson the
nimsovich Larson opening which
transposes into some sort of an English
as Carlson claims the center with C4 and
gukesh immediately counter-strikes with
D5 a kind of scandi-like approach by
gukesh as Carlson brings his night out
with Tempo and chases the queen back to
E6 and now the other night comes out
gukesh developing his Queen's bishop and
probably preparing to Castle queenside a
very unconventional opening approach but
something tells me the gukesh is still
in his opening preparation he is
blitzing out these unconventional moves
so quickly in an early Queen side Castle
exciting enterprising chess as we have
come to expect baigukash and Carlson he
could have brought the bishop out to C4
and Chase the queen but the queen wants
to go to G6 anyway and so Carlson
choosing a more modest developmental
Approach at five baigukesh claiming more
of the center and Carlson castling King
side so we have officially opposite side
castling and Carlson allowing yukash to
drive a stake into the center go cash
doing just that and forcing the Knight
onto G5 where it attacks the queen a
little bit of hesitation there by the
Indian Grandmaster Queen has to move
where will it go Queen to G6 is the
natural Square to move to because that
Queen would x-ray the king along the G
file Carlson likely would drop the
Knight back to H3 and perhaps rerouted
to F4 no but Queen to E8 a very
interesting approach and surprised
Carlson examining the move there the
queen drops all the way back to the
eighth Rank and now most of gukesha's
pieces are stuck on the last two ranks
and now Carlson for the first time
taking a significant thing and trying to
figure out a way to improve his position
he of course will eventually want to
attack kukesh's King on the queen side
so The Rook from A1 can come into the
game via C1 Carlson could also initiate
a pawn storm with A3 and B4 of course
the Knight on G5 is kind of stuck in the
Nether world it can be chased away with
H6 and perhaps kukash can follow up with
a pawn storm of his own and Carlson
trying to nip that in the bud with a
very instructive move F4 freezing the
Central Pawn chain and in the event of
H6 the Knight will drop back to H3 and
it won't be as easy for gokash to get
his kingside pawns rolling with G7 G5
you can take on poisson if he wants to
but he chooses instead to chase the
Knight away and back the night goes to
H3 gukesh continuing his own develop and
bringing his night out and tucking his
King away to relative safety on B8
escaping the X-ray that the C1 Rook was
exerting and now there's that A3 move by
Carlson pretty standard fare in these
types of positions a3b4 kind of a
reverse first sicilian-like idea and
that pawn can move up to B5 and Chase
the Knight out of C6 and so the C file
will start to clear up and gukesh now
it's his turn to take a bit of a think
he hasn't completed his development but
it's not easy to find a good Square for
his dark squared Bishop Bishop D6 would
run into Knight C3 to B5 and that would
play right into White's hands and go
cash instead moving the other bishop and
optimizing its placement putting it on
E6 and opening up an X-ray of his own
but not against White's King rather
against White's Queen and that very same
Queen can move up to C2 and double up
with the C1 Rook let's see what Magnus
chooses here B4 also comes to mind the
D2 Pawn is a bit of a weakness it's a
backward Pawn but it cannot be easily
attacked perhaps Queen D7 can serve that
purpose as Carlson does indeed complete
uh the plan that he started with A3 and
brings up the pawn chain up to B4 and
gukesh his turn to think he can develop
his bishop and instead he plays Queen to
D7 and so he does find a way to exert
pressure on the D2 Pawn now Rook C2 here
would be the natural move but that runs
into Bishop E6 to B3 pinning the rook
and the queen so Carlson has to play
more creatively here he can go all in he
can throw the kitchen sink at black with
a move like Queen to A4 and sacrifice
the D2 Pawn but once the D2 Pawn Falls
the bishop on B2 is going to be hanging
the pawn on E3 is also going to be
hanging with checks so Carlson maybe
he'll bring his knight from C3 all the
way back to B1 that would be another way
to defend the D2 pawn and the benefit of
that move it would be that it opens up
the C file and exerts more direct
pressure on the C6 Knight and a pretty
long think here by Carlson as he
continues to ponder this critical moment
the pawn could also reach B5 and
counter-attack black knight but then
black snake could Slither its way into
A5 and then chisel its way into B3 so
Carlson has to be careful not to weaken
some of those light squares on the queen
side and more thinking as Carlson
he changes thinking poses and now leans
in and he seems like he's about to make
a move Knight B1 is the move that I
would choose here but Carlson is Carlson
for a reason and that is because he
finds Creative Solutions in critical
moments but Knight B1 is ultimately his
choice and gukesh pre-moved 97 as he
shifts the Knight back to E7 and Carlson
slams his Bishop into E5 and that was
the drawback of gukesha's last move the
C7 Pawn is under Fire and gukesh uses
his other Knight to defend that pawn But
Here Comes Carlson's other bishop and it
exerts pressure on D5 I didn't like
gukesh's decision to move his Knight
away from C6 it feels like Carlson now
is firmly in control of the initiative
the bishop on E5 is a pest the pawn on
C7 is under Fire so Knight G6 perhaps
would serve the purpose of chasing the
bishop away but gouquet she does it from
the other side instead he moves his King
away and now the pawn on C7 if necessary
can advance to C6 and lend some much
needed support to the Knight on D5 which
is now under even more fire as Carlson
brought his lady out to B3 and he's got
a little battery aimed at the D5 Knight
dukesh doesn't have anything going on
the other side of the board we haven't
even talked about a black attack against
White's King in a long time perhaps it's
time for black to prepare something like
that but gukesh continues instead to
play on the queen side the Knight comes
back where it started on C6 and chases
the bishop back to its fianchetto Square
on B2 and finally gukesh starting to
prepare something resembling a king side
operation but will he be in time as
Carlson redevelops his Knight to C3 and
the pressure on the D5 Knight has
reached a peak and black cannot take on
C3 the E6 Bishop would have fallen with
Tempo so gukesh he strikes at the king
side and we've got a big trade in the
center as the Queens come off the board
and two pairs of minor Pieces come off
the board and what do we make of this
resulting end game it actually doesn't
look all that bad for the Indian Grand
Master the pawn on D2 is still hanging
Black's King is relatively safe and
Carlson he has to waste a Tempo to
defend that backward
sends his Jeep on forward chases the
Knight back to F2 and the King side is
now basically locked up both kings are
actually relatively safe so the position
is now a lot more strategic in nature
and gokesh uses the queen side in order
to shatter White's Pawn chain A5 was an
excellent move very alert by gokash and
he creates a weakness on A3 Ned Carlson
now has to defend with his other rocket
feels very much Lego cash is now in
charge on the board and on the clock
Carlson with 12 seconds on the board to
about 25 for kukash as the bishops come
off the board as well and Carlson's
Knight it Cycles back to H1 and what a
move as the Knight jumps around forward
to G3 in order to put pressure on
Black's only weakness the F5 Pawn which
black has to keep under supervision
right now The Rook on A5 is doing the
job of laterally defending the F5 pawn
and wukash sending his own Knight back
how many beautiful night Maneuvers have
we had in this game and gukesh he
centralizes his Knight where is it going
to go from E6 well nowhere for now he's
going to improve his Pawn structure and
Carlson is going to do the same and
black is going to bring his King up and
the pod on A4 there was Untouchable so
good Cash He over protects the F5 Pawn
with his other rook and he guarantees a
nice platform for his Knight on D3 and
he continues to put pressure on Carlson
who seems to be on his last legs and is
Carlson dropping the A4 Pawn I think
ukesh could have taken that pawn but
instead he moves his Rook back to A7 he
hesitated and now he brings his Knight
to D3 He was threatening a fork on C1
alertly Carlson brings his Rook back but
here goes kukesha's pawns he shoves his
Pawn down to B4 and Carlson trying to
use his a pawn to generate counter play
but he's gonna lose that pawn and he
clings to it with both of his Rooks he
doubles on the a file but can gukesh
send his b-pawn further up the board can
he play B3 kukash using his last seconds
to calculate the variations and
patiently shifts his Rook over to B5 he
follows the rule Rook behind the pawns
and in comes the pawn to B3 it goes and
after a little has a 2b2 it goes and he
forces The Rook to be won and who cash
finally eliminates Carlson's only source
of counter play the A6 pawn and a
last-ditch attempt by the world champion
he ain't done yet and who cash might
have blundered a little bit there he's
given up the F5 Pawn but Carlson chooses
not to take it he instead brings his
King into the rescue and bukash chases
the night away he forces the Knight to
take the F5 Pawn but jumps the Knight to
D6 and he stops Rook C4 and Carlson
eliminates another pod on e4 and he's
turning this game around as we've seen
him do so many times he's brought his
Knight back to C3 he's won two of
gokash's Pawns and go cash has been
unable to promote the bee pawn and now
it's Carlson's turn to push upon on the
other side of the board suddenly a pawn
is on F6 and his gukesh who has to send
his pieces back to stop the pawn and
Carlson with his last seconds can he
find a way to squeeze that pawn through
to F7 a lot of hesitation and again the
Knight mounts a journey to E4 and
there's a C5 square that go cash has to
watch out for and there's F7 for single
cash to take that pawn we've got a trade
of Brooks Carlson with a fork on D6 and
takes the pawn on C4 and he's also going
to win The Pawn on B2 but in return go
cash he's going to take the pawn on G2
and we've got yet another end game and
this is very much a three result game
can go cash get to that H2 pawn and he
does and 91 was clearly missed by
Carlson who shakes his head Knight F3 is
going to come with great effect Carlson
shoves his Central pawns up the board
we're gonna have a pawn race to end this
game this game just never seems to end
D5 check by Carlson is he gonna push his
other Pawn up to E5 but gukash seems to
be faster here because one school cash
takes the pawn on H2 well then his pawns
are going to be harder to stop Black's
King is right in the middle of White's
Pawn chain making it harder for Carlson
to advance his pawns and here comes
gukesh G3 on the board Carlson brings
his Knight back to the rescue and H3 is
on the board and wukesh is going to jump
his Knight back with check oh Knight G4
check and he's gonna play H2 and he's
going to promote first but the game is
still not over Carlson he's gonna take
the Knight then he's going to take the
pawn he does it in the other order and
gukesh still has to win this game he
keeps checking the white king but he
doesn't seem to be able to make progress
and now it's Carlson pushing his Pawn up
to D6 does Magnus Carlson now have a
miraculous Fortress the king moves up to
D7 dukesh almost lost on time there he
is trying to separate to separate the
king from the E5 Pawn but Carlson he is
managing to keep his King on a square
where it defends the Knight and the pawn
at the same time who cash might have to
force a draw here I don't see a win much
less with five seconds on the board
gokash has to be careful you could
easily miss a fork here and he's trying
to shoulder whites King off of its
dominant post on F4 so Carlson just
shuffles his Knight and black can't
bring the king up to E6 it would have
gotten forked on G5 and it still will
get fourth and gukash continues to
repeat the position trying to
desperately find the best Square for the
queen but White's Knight is expertly
blocking off all the important tracks
and Carlson's King did get separated
there but E6 check oh my goodness and
now Carlson is winning chances which
Pawn is he gonna push he pushes D7 but
he's got to be careful Knight B5 check
last seconds how does Carlson defend E6
he might have overpressed King to D6
runs it to Queen D3 check he goes Knight
T4 he still tries to keep his pawns
protected and off we go again gukesh
keeping his Queen between White's King
and white spawns and E7 check was a
blunder and Magnus forgot that go cash
could take D7 he thought the gukash had
to take E7 and then the White Knight
would have forked black screen and
forced to draw and instead Carlson makes
the final blunder and what a Monumental
win for gukesh what a game and if you
enjoyed this video make sure to click
the link of the playlist for more of
these Blitz videos thank you so much for
watching
[Music]